security is tight outside the
pro-kurdish Peoples Democratic Party or
HTTP headquarters in the air back in
southern Turkey these policemen are
getting a peaceful protest by men and
women demanding the return of their
children who they say have been
kidnapped or recruited by the Kurdish
Workers Party PKK holding the pictures
of their missing children they call for
their quick return they took my daughter
away and we haven't heard from her for
the past five years we don't know if she
is still alive these protests was
started in September by one mother but
now others and male family members of
those they say and now in the runs of
the PKK have joined them a common claim
among the protesters is that their
children were last seen here at the
offices of the HDP party and they say
that's why they've continued their
sit-in outside the party offices party
officials however deny any links to the
PKK and say they've also never actively
recruited for the organization some
former PKK fighters have returned to
their family since the protests began
and that is giving hope to people here
who's near caius daughter McKee recently
returned from Iraq where she fought
under the PKK she is still in custody
awaiting trial for being a member of the
group that's outlawed in Turkey but her
mother says regardless of that she's
relieved to his back my daughter was 14
when she was kidnapped I thank God that
after five long years she surrendered
three days ago I'm so happy my daughter
is out of the hands of those tyrants two
weeks ago Joffre jaylen also returned to
his family he says he deserted the PKK a
company in Syria after seeing his mother
on the protests in media reports that
life is difficult you are constantly
fighting and have little time to miss
home or family finally though you get
disgusted by all the death and
destruction and you start missing your
loved ones
the PKK has been designated a terrorist
organization by Turkey the EU and the
United States it launched a separatist
insurgency in southeast Turkey 1984
since then more than 40,000 people
mostly Kurds have been killed in
fighting with Turkish forces Kurds
account for roughly 20% of turkeys
population of about 80 million people
after decades of marginalization by the
Turkish state they've been demanding
greater rights and more autonomy but for
many here the HDP and PKK have dragged
their relatives into fighting that's
more to do with the group's interests
than it is with the flight of the
Karishma mohammad al jazeera Diyarbakir
southern turkey